[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si on peut tuer en fait tu es en feu
néanmoins je suis on veut tuer on veut
je suis en feu
[Musique]
je mets alors je vais vous dire je mets
8 sur 10 à tous et caroline
on a choisi pour une chanson de mylène
farmer je suis libertine étonnant c'est
pas moi j'ai choisi des paroles alors je
ne les connais pas bon on va la tenter
c'est parti
[Musique]
quant aux vertus
je la dérange évidemment il avait
terminé ses jeux je suis si fragile un
bien sûr car ni turbine chez vous mais
je jeu dans la lutte dans le direct fait
ça je dois bien là pour rigoler mais si
la tension
jean michel maire la ville henri
schaller jeu on vous a choisi vous il
articulé à matt pokora
cette année là mais je pense que c'était
une cote de contrat à 62 chf 61 à bachs
pas ça ça d'accord rien dit très sympa
[Applaudissements]
le côté
mais elle bat
à eux deux les chanteurs donnent des
nains des gens lors d'un homme était
l'idole des jeunes
l année cette année-là et bimbo citoyen
je vous étonner plus sûr du monde
il promet de nous mais de dos pas la
victoire ce n'est pas le v de la
victoire c'est le deux d'accord moati
raymond on a choisi mhd les trois
compères et ça c'est une de mes chansons
préférence d'euros c'est parti c'est la
championne slicks et la chanteuse claire
et la championne slicks et la championne
slicks et la championne flic c'est la
championne slick la championne stick
c'est la championne slicks
[Applaudissements]
c'était passionnant que j'attendais je
crois que les anémies la nouvelle qui a
été avec des roues plus dur est
franchement et voulez quoi
il l'a bien fait et moi je serai majdi
j'aurais pas écrit de parole juste assez
la champion s league peut pas on peut
pas lui ça ne dit on peut pas la faire
en bonus track avec vous vos ministres
non mais moi j'aurai fait moins bien que
bon on va voir on va les y tu sûr cela
permettra dès lors c'est la championne
si championne se rencontrent jamais il
était mieux il était muet mais pour
l'instant c'est pas sa note puisque ça
n'était pas sa chanson à gilbert m
gilles verdez on a choisi allumé l'os
audio diaby est d'accord c'est vraiment
un mahmoud se met en garde ses prêts à
bas taux fait la maman qui me demandent
comment faire mathieu delormeau et va
mieux là plus l'oreillon chou-fleur 1
c'est dépassé qu'est-ce que ça se
déplacer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
s'ils n'ont rien pu face à ces déplacés
il va mieux mathieu normaux il sera là
incessamment sous peu on me dit
peut-être demain et d'après demain
peut-être lundi voilà où peut-être
septembre il va revenir alors mathieu va
mieux en tout cas c'est la bonne
nouvelle on leur rase notre matou voilà
qui se repose il a des piqûres tous les
soirs et une infirmière qui vient le
matin et soir il a des piqûres et ouais
le pauvre main merci gilles allumer le
feu et c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allumez away allumer le feu allumé le
feu allumé
allumée
et l'eau sont sûrs de regard allumé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un gars ton juste que mes chiens
ah oui j'étais dans le rythme était non
non non non parole c'était pas ça reste
un mec la colonne s'est allumé j'imagine
le gavage est génial les voisins a
allumé et hop tu vas l'allumette on sort
là attention je finirai par vous tiens
j'vais pas où je vous ai déjà chanté et
doha enora on vous a choisis et nora une
chanson une chanson qui vous ressemble
passe partout les sept nains hi hi hi ou
[Rires]
dans l'eau pas vrai et aux façades hors
série s'arrête jamais fait alors c'est
quoi alors s'étale à wuwei venir êtes
vous réveiller mais on m'a pris pour un
con j'ai connu les parties
[Musique]
mon cher
soeur
quelle peur
comment
et apporte aussi la main non je la
connais pas ta ta ta ta ta ta bah quoi
inventer ban à la la la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis zéro je vous mets un merci parce
qu'il était quand même sur le boxeur et
les paroles gaza oui oui oui la colle et
qu il aurait dû tout les faire parce que
c'est une chanson que j'adore celle ci
mais oui mais oui il faut inventer des
paroles valent bien raison la mienne
fait la faire partir des attentions
jean luc lemoine pas c'est une de mes
chansons préférées aussi un ouais c'est
vrai que dorée je n'aime que toi et nord
je n'aime que toi non plus tu sais pas
mais à la sauce de soja
c'est slimane paname attention c'est
parti
[Musique]
non
mais ça
[Musique]
on arrive là et mon sac à dos paname
paname on arrive
nana na na nana na na - 12 12 - ou 0
pour l'instant c'est qu'aux conséquences
en tête avec 9 9 sur 10 vous savez la
fondation disent non au oui oui je sais
pas ça ne fait 8 il est passé à neuf
parce que les niveaux il est passé à
neuf
attention alors vous je suis un bon bah
on appris aujourd'hui que vous adorez
attend samir j'ai cherché asile mais
alors pas du tout la connais pas c'est
parti mailloux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne sais pas du tout la chanson you're
ou mais je viens faire ramener ses yeux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'était la plus de femme
peints un nul 0 match et c'est derrick
tait partie